so many lives would transform overnight
if they realized my life sucks I have
nothing going for me really means I have
nothing to lose and that makes you a
very dangerous person
so
in any kind of game position so like in
business right
every position has advantages and
disadvantages and a lot of people look
at the really big guys and they're like
man they uh they like they're like
they're looking at me like must be easy
for Alex right and I remember when we
had uh Jim watch and we had a very big
company I would tell the guys who are
coming out was like if you're trying to
compete against me I was like you have
advantages I was like if you're on a
sales call you're like listen you're
just a number to Alex you're never gonna
talk to Alex right here with me you're
going to get my attention I'm the one
right I was like that's how you're gonna
throw stones at me I was like but on the
flip side if it's me marketing to the
masses I'm gonna be like this kid's in
his mom's basement he has no idea what
he's doing he's been in business for 12
months and of course he has no idea like
wouldn't you want somebody who's
thousands of success stories behind it
because we've made a system like both
sides have advantages and so what
happens is people are in this small
position where they're more Nimble they
can give more personalized attention to
people Etc
and they see it as a pure disadvantage
and so you can flip the fact that you
have nothing going for you with you have
nothing to lose and that means that you
can take lots of risks very quickly and
end up in the exact same position you
are which is nothing and so if you
eliminate downside it should decrease
your action threshold meaning you should
be able to do more things faster rather
than do fewer things because you don't
have a great life or things going for
you and so I think if people flip that
a lot more people would take action
because they actually realize the
advantage of their position Jack butcher
says you get rich by taking lots of risk
with small amounts of money and you stay
Rich by taking small amounts of risk
with lots of money yes I wholeheartedly
agree I didn't know that was his quote
uh he may have repurposed it there's
something called Chilean drift do you
know what that is no so it's a a
phenomenon at the core it's not the
opposite it's that um quotes that
weren't said by Churchill often get like
erroneously attributed to him it's like
all quotes lead back to Churchill even
though they didn't and Socrates yeah
it's like it's just one of those things
where it's like I I think Churchill once
said get rich by making large amounts
it's like no he [__] but there's
another one as well uh that a good
friend James Smith talked about which is
if you're succeeding at a job that you
hate imagine how good you'd be at a job
that you loved and that's kind of the
same this person is starting from
essentially zero how much [__] worse
can it get right
is the downside if you can eliminate
someone's downside for action it's like
then
the bias it should bias you towards
taking action why is it that
people in that case if they do have
nothing to lose still feel like they
have lots to lose because I think most
the times so this I think this is really
important is that
they have nothing objectively to lose
and so everything that they feel like
they have to lose is purely made up in
their mind it's stories that tell
themselves about what other people are
going to think about them when those
people aren't even think about them to
begin with right but like that's where
they live all of their lives or live out
all of the potential downside is in the
mere reflection of what other people
will think about them in the future
should they fail
and I think that is the like if we were
if we're trying to get real and I'm like
talking to somebody's like well I I mean
because I know that if I actually had
somebody in front of me they'd start
squirming right if I said the first
thing right like you have nothing to
lose and then because then they do have
something to lose and I just have to
name it for them and be like okay who's
the person in your mind who's the voice
it's like blah blah blah six questions
deep it's my uncle okay why like let me
state it this way will
your belief that you're going to be
viewed as a failure by your uncle be the
sole reason that you live the rest of
your life below your potential and
regret everything that you don't do
because of Uncle Tom
that's the wrong one Uncle Harry
when you say it like that all of a
sudden they're like I don't want to let
Uncle Harry have that kind of power and
then all of a sudden it breaks and then
they like get free of it and so I think
it's getting really specific and really
narrow on the because people say it's
Society it's other people it's like it's
usually one or two voices and if you can
get really specific on whose voice it is
then you can name it and then like I
think I'm a big believer in like shame
only exists in the shadows which is like
once you put it in the light you look at
it and you're like
my mom that was really it like when I
really think about it it's because it's
not even just my mom it's my mom in this
circumstance when I come back home for
Thanksgiving I just am so afraid of the
comment that she's gonna make it's like
well what if we confront that okay your
mom you sit down at Thanksgiving dinner
and you haven't made money yet and you
quit your job now what
is that better than you spending the
next 60 years hating her or resenting
her for the fact that she held you back
and then it's like when you give the
real scenario they're like well [__] and
then like this weight comes off and
they're like [__] I guess I should do
this and you're like yeah shame on me
Shadows is nice I like that and it
definitely is cleansing to just be like
look here it is out in front of you yeah
and it really you realize just how
irrational it is because we don't want
to look at it yeah because it's in the
shadow and we put it in the shadows
because of how it makes us feel about
ourselves in my opinion and so it's it's
so scary we avoid it we avoid it we
avoid avoid it but it's like I think the
faster you can kind of build that muscle
of like huh I've got this hesitation
what is the real reason because like
logically I can do that whole thing cool
you have nothing to lose you're poor
great zero all right okay but then what
is it that I'm that I do have something
to lose it's relational Capital it's
status within my tiny micro community
that doesn't matter but like my
perceived status okay name the names and
but by pulling it out from the Shadows
it'll but like that confrontation from
here to here is I think where all the
fear is
because it's embarrassing
to be like it's my mom the other perfect
thing or great realization I think for
anybody that's starting out and is
feeling self-conscious about what other
people are going to think is when you're
starting out by Design there are so few
people looking at you that even if you
do fail no one [__] sees right so
this is something we realized when we
were running nightclubs that we would
try and launch a new event around
freshers week in September and we would
we would have this great idea and it
would be everything would be about
flamingos or everything would be it
would be a smart night on a Tuesday so
people could go out after they've been
to sports club or whatever it was
and then it would flop right and we'd do
150 people and all of the guys that work
for us would be stood outside looking
destitute and upset and they're good so
unbearables there so it looks like
there's more room oh dude we had so many
tricks we'd pump the pump the room full
of smoke we would pad the back off so
that everyone had to go to the front we
get the DJ to play music all sorts of
[__] but all of the boys would be like
[__] this makes us look so bad
everyone's gonna think that we're [__] I
was like no no no no 150 people are
gonna think that we're [__] like the
advantage of running a [__] business
that doesn't reach many people is that
not many people saw your [__] business
and that's when you're starting out
people that are concerned about becoming
a content creator I I'm worried about
starting a podcast because what if
everyone sees how [__] my podcast is
it's like dude no one's going to see
your [__] podcast it took me three years
three and a half years to get even an
appreciable amount of people listening
to this show and it was effort three
times a week no one cares when you start
so you can be liberated from that as
well and it's just objection handling
objection handling objection handling
all the way down I think a lot I think a
couple frames that are just different
frames around content making since we're
on the topic
um that helped me was one is seeing it
as practice rather than the game
so like when we're doing a podcast if
you start you're like hey I'm gonna do a
podcast I'm gonna post it's practice for
me getting better for future me rather
than like I'm like this is the main game
it's like no the game is the whole thing
and this is just like we're still in
pre-season like these these these scores
these touchdowns don't even matter yet
right now you can say yet even though
like I can still feel like I'm a
preseason but I think from a mental
framework it actually decreases the
stakes associated with doing it and I
think that's been helpful for me
especially it was in the earlier days
the other one was um kind of the equal
opposite of this problem which is not
wanting to start because no one's
watching because it feels like you're
doing all this work what's the point and
so I actually the little mental trick
that I had was um one I track lots of
stuff and the more ways you track the
more ways you can win and so it's a
little thing that I found out so like if
you track 100 stats and you only need
one of them to go up so you feel like
you made some progress so that's like an
easy one and the second thing around the
tracking is that I would look at like
the biggest possible number so a lot of
times you can see like the impressions
of you know a post that you make even if
you only got like 16 likes I got like
100 Impressions and I thought to myself
I was like well if there was a room of
100 people I'd be stoked like that would
be awesome especially in the early days
I was like that would be I would totally
feel like that was worthwhile and so
taking those little impression numbers
and pretending that they were like micro
events that I was making the work or the
content for all of a sudden made it feel
worth it for me and so the combination
of I can have a small room and I'm
really impacting like when I get a view
that has like 13 views on it you know
for like a video in the early days I'd
be like well shoot I made this video and
13 people saw I was like a small room
like that works but
looking at both absolute growth and
relative growth so it's like okay well I
went from 10 followers this month to 15
followers this month it's like well you
can say that you only gain five
followers I was like or you can say that
you gained by you went up by 50 and that
was exciting and so then I because I'm a
Excel projection guy I was like okay
well if I do this every month and the
team knows this because I project
everything out I'm like if we do this
because I I'll predict where we're going
to be in like 12 months and how about
usually hit it very really very but how
do you account for the unforeseen
5 million play
video that comes in well that's my
padding right so like I'll project that
with no white swan events where
something good happens yeah but it just
if we keep doing what we're currently
doing at this trajectory we compound at
13 a month yeah that's what it is right
now so 13 monthly and that's just on one
of the platforms we're on
um and so I can just see what we're
going to be at six months and that's
exciting so James Smith gamifies it in
the same way you're busy yeah absolutely
exactly the same way and he always says
that it's just like playing uh levels on
a computer game in this month wow like I
got another XP point or whatever and I
think that's very important because
social media and the fact that it is
associated with status even though
everybody says oh you know it doesn't
really matter and blah blah it does like
it's very hard for us to remove the
human hierarchy from what is evidently
just Quantified [__] status right on
a screen and what he did was he removed
himself a lot existentially from that by
saying it's not comment on my worth as a
person it's not a comment on whether I'm
you know going to be loved or accepted
by the world
it's me putting some stuff out and wow
we won this month yeah and this month oh
maybe we didn't win why didn't we win
where I go back the same way as if
someone beats you at FIFA unless you
like a pro FIFA Player or whatever but
again with that what's the difference
between the the amateur FIFA Player and
the pro FIFA Player the pro has put his
existential connection right to his
content and the success of it oh my God
so many little things on this that I
want to go into one of them is uh so Dr
Kashi is my closest friend he's like a
behavioral whatever loves studying why
humans do things
um and so people who are most successful
a lot of times with their it's not that
they necessarily have more willpower
they find ways to they find other ways
to reward themselves
and so he's like the more skills you
have the more ways you have to reward
yourself and so somebody who somebody
can extend how long their time Horizon
is because they do gamify it so people
who don't have the skills of figuring
out ways to reward themselves in the
meantime can't make it the whole way but
that's like when you're doing cardio and
you're like okay it's 5 30 you know it's
five times five to get out of here right
you you create micro games within the
longer game to keep yourself going and
the thing is I've seen that across uh
verticals so like if you look at uh so
Travis mesh is a Olympic lifter Olympic
lifting coach out of North Carolina and
he has this really cool way of getting
lifters to PR every workout so have a
personal record every workout and what
he does is he have them map every single
set in rep range for every single lift
at every weight and so what happens is
all you have to do is go through your
book of 200 lifts and every single
weight and you can always find one that
you did a year ago and I'm like this is
my eight rep max PB on good mornings yes
and you're like well I can hit nine on
this or I can add five pounds to it and
so every workout they win yeah and so
they get excited because they get
rewarded every workout and so that's why
it's like the more ways you track the
more ways you can win and then I think
that that's those little micro wins can
keep you going over the long game that
you have to just keep playing every
single learning for over three years now
I've started my day the exact same way
which is with element in Walton element
contains a science-backed electrolyte
ratio of sodium potassium and magnesium
and it is the best Hydra Asian drink
that I've ever found it tastes fantastic
it's super refreshing orange is just the
most OP flavor in the world it's
absolutely phenomenal and it helps to
play a critical role in reducing muscle
cramps and fatigue it regulates your
appetite it optimizes brain health and
it helps curb Cravings they're also the
exclusive hydration partner to Team USA
weightlifting and relied on by tons of
Olympic athletes and everyday High
performers all around the world also
there is a no BS no questions asked
grief and policy where you can buy a box
completely risk-free and if you do not
like it for any reason they will give
you a refund during an unlimited
duration and you don't even need to
return the box that's how confident they
are that you'll love it element are
giving away a free sample pack of all
eight flavors with your first box if you
go to the link in the description box
below or drink lmnt.com
MW that's drink lmnt.com
MW what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
[Music]